emmy-winning actor and rapper riz ahmed
he earned his first oscar nomination
this year for his compelling performance
in sound of metal ahmed is the first
muslim ever nominated for best actor
it's also been nearly 20 years since a
man of asian heritage was nominated in
the category
the visceral low-budget film was shot in
just 26 days
and is up for six awards including best
picture
ahmed says the project was an unusual
but welcome
challenge your hearing is deteriorating
rapidly in sound of metal
riz ahmed transforms into reuben stone
a heavy metal drummer and recovering
heroin addict
who suddenly loses his hearing
i can't hear you do you understand me i
can't i'm deaf
i'm dead you invested an awful lot in
this part
yeah it was very demanding in the seven
months ahmed was preparing for the role
the 38 year old became fluent in
american sign language
immersed himself in addiction recovery
groups
and spent hours each day with his drum
instructor
you know typically two of us just
stripped down to our socks in our
underpants just sweating in his basement
uh doing solos how hard did you find it
learning the drums
i found it very hard i'm not gonna lie i
i had hoped that being a rapper
would help me i was very much wrong your
director in
sound of metal darius martyr described
you as a shape-shifter
is that accurate i grew up in a way them
meant i had to
shift my shape a lot it was about
surviving
socially and i think i certainly for
some of my career at least
up until this point was interested in
shape shifting and transforming
out of myself and i think now i'm
interested in more is going to a
personal place
some of his most personal work is as a
musician
rapping under the alias rhys mc once we
were kings when will we be kings no more
salah
we believe in last year
he released a critically acclaimed
concept album
under his own name called the long
goodbye
ahmed learned to captivate crowds at a
young age growing up in north london
i started rapping as soon as i
discovered my brother's
hidden uh stash of hip-hop cassettes
that he told me explicitly not to listen
to because they had swearing on them
so as soon as he left the house as a 10
year old i was there just memorizing
wu-tang clan lyrics i always felt that
there was this volcano inside of me
bursting to get out
when did you first start acting i think
in a way i've been acting since i was a
young kid
i came from a working class pakistani
household but then i got scholarships to
go to
predominantly white upper class private
schools
so i kind of in a way feel like i was
changing costume changing character
every day growing up but it was really
some school teachers that realized that
okay
this kid's got a bit too much
hyperactive energy we need to do
something with it
it was really something that anchored me
through teenage years that were
you know somewhat troubled but ahmed
never imagined he could make a career
of performing i'm curious if there was
one particular direction you thought you
might be headed in
yeah i thought i was heading the
direction of not being able to do any of
it
and it was interesting in a way you know
to kind of enter
um a profession with no expectations
can actually be very liberating because
you dance like no one's watching no one
is watching
ahmed was in a string of indie films in
the uk
but had yet to make it big i was
thinking of giving up acting at that
point
because i'd really hit a wall in my
career then came
a pivotal audition to co-star with jake
gyllenhaal
in the 2014 thriller nightcrawler
initially were you told you weren't
right for that part yeah very much so
making peace with what you don't have
that's what it's all about that again
kind of took a certain pressure off i
think i kind of thrive
in situations where people don't see me
coming yeah you know i kind of probably
enjoy being the underdog
he got a call back they said in order to
get to the next round you have to come
to la
but we can't fly you out there so pretty
much with what i had left in my bank
account i booked that flight and and
thought i'd just
take a chance the breakout role launched
ahmed's career in the u.s
finally opening doors to high-profile
films and franchises like star wars
rogue one and marvel's venom
and he was cast as the protagonist in
the gripping
hbo drama the night of riz
ahmed that performance won him the lead
actor emmy
in 2017. he was the first asian and
first muslim
to win the award if this show has shown
a light
on some of the prejudice in our society
islamophobia
some of the uh injustice in our justice
system then
maybe that's something and while ahmed
could make history
at this year's academy awards he says
the real win
is seeing new kinds of stories on screen
we all know what it is to feel like an
outsider and so for myself with this
character and with this project it was
really fascinating to play someone who
falls between the cracks of hearing
culture and deaf culture
and what he realized is the same thing
that i realized and i hope audiences do
which is that
deafness actually isn't a disability for
many people it's it's a culture
have you given any thought to a speech
an acceptance speech no i
i haven't to be honest this is a film
that was made on a shoestring budget
with just
a lot of heart a lot of dedication a lot
of blood sweat and tears you know
literally
and to see it get that recognition
that's everything well you certainly put
your heart into it
i did you know i actually said to darius
after we shot the film
you know if no one sees this it's okay
i've gotten so much from this experience
already
so um that doesn't mean i don't want
people to see it i'd actually love it if
people saw the film
check it out yeah and you should see it
he's unbelievable in this movie it's a
small film but he makes it big
uh he's an incredible actor and again
one of the things that really struck me
in that conversation when i asked him
when did you start acting
and he said in a way i've always been
acting and it's you know he's had to in
effect across cultures growing up
in england listen i saw him in the night
the night of on hbo
he was knockout in that he was that was
such a great series and he was so good
but i like this anthony where he says i
thrive in places where people don't see
me coming
i always think it's always good to be
underestimated and then over delivered
it seems like he's done that time and
time again
yeah i'm glad you mentioned the night up
too because that's a sensational series
that i think a lot of people missed all
right and you can hear more of my
conversation with riz ahmed
on today's cbs this morning podcast